we think we know what it's like to be in
darkness but we don't not complete
darkness we're all lights have been
extinguished the blind theater in 1
Osiris provides that experience an
electric doll we put the audience in a
situation which normally the main
stimulus is visual so this person is now
disconnected from their phone and other
sources of information for more than an
hour having to concentrate solely on
what is happening in front of them but
what does the bueno Syrus theater-going
public hope to get from the darkness it
surprised me it was unique a sensation I
hadn't expected it when you're in there
it stimulates all your senses it's
fabulous
it works everything out smell hearing
imagining things you can't see but can
understand many of the actors know the
theatre staff are blind or partially
sighted the work is perfect for people
with impaired vision I'm partially
sighted for instance at first it was
difficult to get used to total darkness
but you do we saw a production called
Lucy's la revolucion or lights the
revolution a story of forbidden love
during Argentina's 19th century fight
for independence there was plenty of
sound a movement I felt the wind on my
face and smelt herbes and chocolate you
have to learn how to live in darkness
complete darkness - as the theater
slogan goes see what you can't see and
then emerging into the light try to see
life with different eyes
there is also a show for children than
the pure musical experience a blind
gourmet meal with singing in the comedy
on Saturdays six different shows I will
feel about gone in there is a feedback
from the audience you feel a development
of their perception not just from their
emotions but you feel their movements
their palpitations even though you can't
see them the relationship is still there
it's surprising what you can find in
total darkness illumination perhaps
through the senses that don't see thanks
wine there al Jazeera 1 Osiris